and finally new rule the only time there
should be two national anthems is when
the other team is from canada
this season the nfl has added lift every
voice and sing commonly known as the
black national anthem to the
star-spangled banner before games and
two weeks ago i opined that it was fine
to get rid of the old anthem
we just shouldn't have two
you know if you watch the show for
opinions and you want to know what the
correct opinion on the anthem is
that's it
that's the correct one
we shouldn't have two
[Applause]
the program the view last week devoted a
lot of time to this while somehow
avoiding what i actually said
it seemed to be a lot about a need to
school me on the black national anthem
itself whoopi goldberg said we need two
anthems because quote we're having to
re-educate people because now there
nothing ever goes wrong when you start
talking about re-education
just ask chairman mao
maybe we can set up some sort of camps
now
i don't believe we should enforce
patriotism by singing anything
and if there's one thing i hate more
than group think it's audience
participation
but i am what you might call an old
school liberal who was brought up with
the crazy idea that segregating by race
is bad
that's what i was talking about
and
and
again when it comes to an anthem it
doesn't have to be the one we currently
use but it has to be just one you know
cause it's a national anthem
and symbols of unity matter and
purposefully fragmenting things by race
reinforces a terrible message that we
are two nations hopelessly drifting
apart from each other that's not where
we were even 10 years ago and it's not
where we should be now
where we should be now is here there is
not a black america and a white america
and latino america and asian america
there's the united states of america
[Music]
oh yeah that guy
timothy askew a professor at clark
atlanta university wrote an entire book
about lift every voice and sing
and he said to sing the black national
anthem suggest that black people are
separatist and want to have their own
nation this means that everything martin
luther king jr believed about being one
nation gets thrown out the window
thanks professor you'll be hearing from
whoopi
but he's right if we have two anthems
why not three or five why not a woman's
anthem a latino anthem a gay trans
indigenous peoples an asian pacific
islander anthem
because
i'm not dealing with you i'm not
speaking to you is not a way you can run
a country and most people of all
backgrounds understand that already and
don't even want to try to do it that way
i'm not out of step
believing in separate but equal that's
out of step by 67 years
[Applause]
no
it was 67 years ago in 1954 when the
supreme court handed down their landmark
brown versus board of education ruling
which said
separate but equal
isn't what we do here we decided we're
going to try to make this work together
and yet a recent survey of 173 colleges
found that 42 percent offer segregated
residences 46 offers segregated
orientation programs 72 percent host
segregated graduation ceremonies
well congratulations liberal parents you
just paid 100 grand for your kid to move
to biloxi mississippi in 1948.
i uh
i thought the whole point of going off
to college was to be exposed to people
from different backgrounds who may not
share all your opinions but you find a
way to get high with them
i mean
we're a nation that professes diversity
as our strength
but now half the kids dorm rooms are
determined by racial purity
the university of michigan dearborn
thought it would be super progressive to
set up one virtual cafe for people of
color and a separate one for white
people you see what i mean about
becoming so woke you come back out the
racist side
the university of ohio suggested a gym
for minorities only i have a hard time
believing that the vast majority of
african americans
care
that in private conversations they're
saying oh i just can't stand doing
squats in front of white people
really we can't even go to the gym
together
because what's next what follows
separate dorms anthem ceremonies cafes
gyms separate neighborhoods that was
redlining
they wouldn't let black people live in
the town where i grew up then they did
the word for that is progress it's where
the term progressive comes from
[Applause]
most americans including nearly 80
of african americans want to live in
racially diverse neighborhoods the black
silent majority seems to be behind the
idea that you can't have a melting pot
with two pots
yes america was born from the original
sin of slavery and redress for that is
certainly still in order but not at the
cost of destroying a country that most
black people now have found a decent
life in with a relatively high standard
of living and don't want to lose and
balkanizing our nation will certainly
cause us to lose it we need to stop
regarding this new woke segregation as
if it's some sort of cultural
advancement it's not
ask yugoslavia
the people of sarajevo muslim catholic
and orthodox lived side by side for
nearly a century it hosted the olympics
in 1984.
ten years later it looked like this
countries do disintegrate into madness
when they indulge their separatist
tendencies who too slaughtering tutsis
in rwanda
catholics and protestants in ireland
sunnis and shiites in iraq hindus and
muslims and kashmir
everyone in afghanistan and that one jew
we need to unite as one nation who come
together and sing one anthem always out
of key
you